microsoft is finally caving in and
they're going to start ditching their
x86 computers and ships and going with
arm based systems yes they have actually
announced a new arm-based mini pc to
compete with apple's m1 chip yes the
chip that disrupted the entire pc
industry especially in the laptop game
so in this video i'm going to explain
why this is such a huge deal and i'm
going to go through the history of
microsoft's moves towards arm and why
this one is the biggest of all and of
course we've got to start with apple and
the reason why we're getting this new
competition from microsoft well if you
didn't already know next month on june 6
apple is gonna have their wwdc
keynote and that is where a lot of us
are expecting apple to reveal their m2
chip along with their m2 base max
including the m2 mac mini so what i'm
gonna do before i get into all the
microsoft stuff is go through some of
those m2 mac mini leaks first of all we
have this one from nine to five mac
which was an exclusive leak saying that
the updated mac mini is gonna have two
different versions one with the m2 chip
and then one with the m2 pro now the
interesting detail is that they said the
m2 mac mini development is nearing
completion and its release date is
expected to be announced sometime later
this year and of course we're hoping for
wwdc next month but the even bigger deal
is that in april mark german said that
apple is now testing third-party apps
with at least nine new m2 max which
includes the m2 mac mini which is
awesome and in case you're curious to
see what it's actually going to look
like zona tech made some awesome renders
showing off the m2 mac mini with a bunch
of different colors as you can see right
here however an interesting detail is
that apple just released a new teaser
image for wwc and it has these memoji
faces from a profile view with a bunch
of different colors now some people are
thinking that these colors could
correspond to the new colors for apple's
m2 macbook air because that is actually
in the rumors that it's gonna have new
colors with white bezels and i
personally think that apple could take
this opportunity and give these colors
to the m2 mac mini as well but now with
that out of the way let's get into the
big news from microsoft today they
announced that they're making a new
native arm version of visual studio 2022
and an arm mini pc so basically
microsoft is prepping for a windows arm
future and this is a huge deal because
it's exactly what apple has done and if
you didn't already know apple's max
sales have been skyrocketing ever since
they made the switch to their own apple
silicon but getting into the actual
article from the verge you can see that
microsoft is working on new native arm
versions of their full visual studio
2022 and vs code visual c plus modern
net 6 and java classic net framework
windows terminal wsl and wsa for running
linux and android apps basically this is
all of their developer programs that
they're now giving armed support which
means they're going in it for the long
haul because if microsoft is spending
this much money on arm this means that
harm is going to be very important to
them for the future and now i do want to
mention that all of these announcements
were made at today's microsoft build
2022 opening keynote by their ceo satya
nadella now listen to this clip because
it is very very important we're entering
a world where every windows computer
will draw on the combined power of cpus
gpus npus and even a new co-processor
did you hear that he said that every
windows pc in the future we're entering
this right now is gonna have a cpu a gpu
and an npu now this is a big deal
because right now traditional pcs you
can build them yourself or you can get
it with a laptop but they come with just
a cpu and just a gpu they do not come
with any sort of npu so what this
basically means is that they are going
to be making chips that are integrated
like apple silicon so everything in one
chip the cpu gpu npu all in one just
like the m1 chip the m1 pro the m1 max
and the m1 ultra this is a big deal
because i can't really see them selling
separate npus that you just slot into
the graphics card pci express lot so
this means they're going to be working
on building all-in-one systems with
all-in-one ships it can also dynamically
shift the load between client and cloud
we are calling it the hybrid loop we're
bringing this to you as a cross-platform
capability through the onyx runtime and
azure ml along with an ai tool chain to
make heterogeneous targeting easy and to
bring this to life we're also announcing
project volterra it's a windows dev kit
with an arm cpu and npu
and it includes native arm 64 visual
studio and dot net support to provide
the same fast familiar and highly
productive experience that you're used
to let's take a look
so they even made this teaser trailer
for their new
volterra mini pc now this is a big deal
because they're trying to get developers
to do this new hybrid loop workflow
which is basically just like apple's
universal 2 where you can build an app
and it supports both the intel x86 chips
and the new apple silicon chips at the
same time so this is microsoft basically
announcing their new transition with
hybrid development for both x86 and arm
this is such a huge deal multiple ports
now the stackable design that is
actually very interesting that's cool
because you know you can't really do
that with apple you can't just combine
two mac minis and have them work
together so that is pretty awesome right
there but the biggest deal out of all
this is that microsoft is finally
bringing support for arm-based ai chips
into windows which is huge because now
they're basically admitting that they
need an npu or a neural engine and
that's going to be combined with the cpu
and gpu to basically improve performance
and efficiency and then going on top of
all of that microsoft just published
this new article called windows on arm
saying that windows has traditionally
run on machines that are powered by x86
processors but more recently it also
runs on devices powered by arm
processors so now they're basically
saying this is where we want to go and
right here they're encouraging
developers to build windows apps that
run on arm and the biggest way that
microsoft is making this possible is
that almost a year ago they announced
arm 64 ec
which basically automatically translates
x86 code into windows arm code just like
rosetta 2 like i already mentioned they
made this happen so they are literally
following in apple's footsteps but
jumping back to microsoft's arm 64 ec
translation feature it actually allowed
windows 11 to run on the apple m1 chip
and this is a big deal because we used
it to run games and apps on an m1
macbook pro as you can see right here
but getting back into why microsoft is
making these huge steps towards arm it's
because apple was making qualcomm and
windows and arm look bad because it just
performs so much better 10 months ago i
made this video saying that intel x86 is
going to be dying sooner than you think
now i don't think it's going to die this
year but the steps that we saw from
microsoft today basically show that
windows and microsoft are slowly trying
to move away from x86 and adopt arm
because it's really the best solution
right now and we actually saw different
companies like steem creating the steam
deck which uses linux and proton to
automatically translate gaming apis from
x86 to the linux based apis and people
are absolutely loving the steam deck so
some gamers are actually already moving
away from x86 based systems because the
steam deck basically runs on arm and
over the past year we've been seeing
more and more articles asking will arm
processors become the new standard for
laptops now a former mac chief of
development did say that windows pcs
will have to follow apple's switch to
arm and i completely believe that
because just the gains in performance
and battery life are just outpacing the
gains of x86 now we already see that
there are a lot of companies trying to
compete with apple in their m1 mainly
qualcomm saying that in late 2023
they're gonna have their own m1 rival
that's going to be available in pcs so
they're working on that and they believe
they can beat apple and now on top of
that samsung and amd last year tried to
combine together to try to fight apple's
m1 ship by pairing an exynos 2200 chip
with amd radeon graphics to new laptops
that should hopefully be coming soon but
in my honest opinion i think all of them
are going to be too late because the m1
chip is already powerful we're expecting
the m2 chip hopefully at wwdc next month
and we already have rumors of apple
working on the m3 chip which could be
released later next year so late 2023
and that i think is gonna totally
outperform any of qualcomm's chips that
they have that are trying to compete
with the m1 so there you guys go this is
a huge push by microsoft showing that
they're willing to basically switch all
their development apps and programs to
support arm which basically shows that
they're making a huge push towards arm
because microsoft owns windows and that
basically controls all of the pc
manufacturers so i'm excited to see what
they come up with now if you totally
disagree with any of my thoughts in this
video go ahead and comment down below
but if you enjoyed it click the circle
above to subscribe for more videos like
this one definitely check out one of
those two right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]